that's not my trash that's someone
else's trash
oh my nail just came off does that count
as trash
i just added to my pile thank you so
much
for doing this i'm really excited that
you're gonna be trying this
eco-friendly challenge zero waste means
trying to send as little as possible to
landfill
and we kind of got into a little bit of
this when i was on your podcast
confidently insecure ever since you were
a guest
i think about you almost every single
day in my little brain because
i've been trying to be more eco-friendly
and all of those tips and advice you
gave me then
i've been trying to implement now so i
am ready for this challenge awesome
so show me your trash i want to see the
trash you made in a regular day it was
an amazon
delivery day for my household so i've
got a lot of
packaging tons of paper towels i do
smoothies
and those veggies come in a lot of
plastic i didn't realize
paper bags from our grocery delivery
some extra cardboard my worst fault
is i eat a lot of individually wrapped
candy
a lot of that's recyclable not too bad
the specific challenges i'm going to
give you for this 24
hour period is one to start a compost
because i know that you have been
wanting to do that i'm gonna challenge
you to sign up for a
csa box which is a community supported
agriculture box
and that essentially is a collection of
local
and seasonal produce that will be sent
from local farms to your home
that'll help you cut down on some of
that plastic packaging
so the third thing i'm going to
challenge you to do is to try to
opt for aluminum and glass over plastic
when you can because it's
more highly recyclable i'm so excited to
do this challenge i'm rooting for you i
know you're gonna do amazing
so i'm gonna use one of these plastic
bags to
see how much trash i collect in a day i
didn't realize how bad k-cups were for
the environment
so i switched over to these feasible
ones and then i have my little
compost bin for my office
i got two coffee makers in this house
because we are tired
that's more like it
i just love coconut i'm glad it's taking
off as an alternative
my biggest issue is paper towels as
trash
we try to reuse them but i got these
little microfiber towels these tiny
little things
do the job and you can you know cut them
up to size and then i'll just
i'll throw them in the wash later in the
week i'm making a smoothie though so i
have
a banana peel in my freezer
i've got my little composting bin i've
just been kind of saving the scraps the
reason why we compost is because when
you put food scraps
in a plastic bag and you send it to the
landfill it
decomposes without air and off gases
methane so when you're composting
you're taking methane out of the
atmosphere because you're letting your
food scraps break down with air
i was fixing a printer and i made two
poppies
that looks like penis it's not it's my
finger
so trash the printer that i was fixing
came from the trash
and i just replaced some gears and now
it's perfectly good so i feel like i'm
finding little ways
to be better you gotta be kidding me
today is the day that i'm like
finishing all of these [ __ ] car ends
and stuff
this is [ __ ] i'm gonna recycle this
for sure thing that i'm not thrilled
about is we do these
meal prepped foods that you just pop in
the microwave because it's so
convenient and tasty and the reason why
we chose this company
is because they donate meals to people
that can't afford them so for every
meal you buy you make it more affordable
for someone else i'm gonna do chicky
that i already made cauliflower bites
and some
mashed sweet potatoes mmm
god damn i love clear up chips my
composting bin came
and i can use this cardboard stuff for
the browns i think
i've got a compost bin
that whole coffee tin of
rotten food out of the freezer into my
composting bin
here is the tare website it looks like
more than a week's worth of veggies
let's go ahead and add one to the cart
38 bucks for all of that to be delivered
right to my door so a tip that i have to
make
drinking water bottles easier for all of
you people out there is to have
multiples of the reusable water bottles
when i wanted water i would have left it
in the car
or downstairs and i'm on the roof or
whatever so i have water bottles in
multiple places for multiple
things this is my yoga and working out
water bottle this stays down here
this stays in my office my boyfriend and
i each have our own
boop it even eases the use of our cups
and needing to do the dishes all the
time i'm actually kind of shocked by how
little trash that i've had all the way
up
to 7pm but i have a feeling dinner might
create a little bit of
cash i realize this like entire video
has pretty much taken place in my
kitchen because that's where i make the
most trash every day apparently
there's my dinner got even worse
sauce and peanuts oh christ that was a
bad one
they normally don't have that many
little side things
oh that looks good
i'm gonna go for sand pellegrinos which
happen to have a piece of foil on top
which is so annoying that i keep just so
happening to choose the things that have
extra pieces of trash on them today but
gotta be honest this is what i would
drink okay in it goes bloop
i've done a lot of reading about
starting from the bottom trying to
change the environment
and i feel really discouraged because a
lot of these articles are saying like
you deciding to use your own bags
instead of targets plastic bags aren't
actually doing anything
i'm like curious to hear what ari thinks
of about like the little small
things like that i think the most
sustainable thing you can do is vote so
vote for
extended producer responsibility which
means
that the trash a company makes they're
responsible for it after you use
the product but i do think that consumer
action and like being a conscious
consumer is important because
ultimately the companies will listen to
the consumers
and want to follow the trends of what
the consumers want
and so maybe your individual ad impact
isn't as big
but if there's enough consumers putting
that pressure on companies
then it's gonna shift the tide it's
gonna make a big impact
ultimately yay thank you so much for
doing this with me i'm using a plastic
reusable bag
and this is the amount of trash that i
made you're doing super well the average
american makes about 4.4 pounds of trash
per day
compared to the average american i think
you're moving along really nicely
you did that to me all your videos like
you've actually
changed like my way of thinking zero
waste was always sort of a gateway drug
for me to get into environmentalism at
large
the biggest impact you can have is
flying less and eating less meat
zero waste is kind of a smaller part of
it but i think it's a really
good way to start thinking about your
impact because you can't see your co2
but you can see the trash you make not
only am i gonna be incorporating this
more into my daily life but i've already
got my partner who lives with me
asking so many questions about all of
the
you know new routines we have so i'm
really excited to kind of like spread
the word and keep passing the knowledge
that
you have bestowed upon me
you